je suis ici aujourd'hui avec vous parce
que
[Musique]
en fait j'en sais rien on va inviter je
suis venu c'est à peu près comme ça que
se passent toutes les choses dans ma vie
je vois de la lumière une porte qui
s'ouvre et j'y vais donc on m'a invité
par ce que m'a dit que j'étais quelqu'un
de passionné heureux et que je le
transmettait on va voir ça aujourd'hui
je suis parti dans la vie avec un petit
package assez classique
je viens d'une famille modeste on peut
dire je suis né avec une petite cuillère
en plastique dans la bouche famille
divorcé j'ai eu un beau père assez cool
qui m'a appris à bricoler on avait un
petit jardin donc j'ai aussi appris à
tondre la pelouse tailler les haies et
met un peu la nature
j'ai un super caractère je suis têtu
très curieux extrêmement timide je suis
quand même là aujourd'hui est dyslexique
à mon avis au moins 1 10e dan je suis
sûr que je fais même des fautes
d'orthographe à l'oral mais bon je suis
parti et que ce petit package et avec
comme seule envie comme seul souhait
être heureux c'est tout c'est un peu
niais mais c'est plutôt cool
me voilà parti dans la vie adolescence
enfance et tout ça s'est plutôt bien
passé au lycée jeanne est en cours
j'apprenais j'ai été assez concentré
comme ça après je pouvais sortir et être
avec les amis je me concentrais après je
pouvais aller faire du vélo
profitez de la vie être heureux à l'eau
cinéma ah non je pouvais pas le cinéma
familles modestes et je voulais pas
demandé d'argent forcément ma mère
problème du coup je me suis dit bon bah
faut que trouver une solution vu que tu
t'es tu es je veux vraiment aller au
cinéma
j'ai commencé à essayer d'utiliser mes
petits savoir bricoler ou tailler des
plots ce genre de choses et j'ai toqué à
la première porte un rideau se poussent
et se remettre mais c'est tout je suis
allé à la porte d'à côté qu'à la porte
d'à côté qu'à la porte d'à côté j'ai
vraiment tu es tu un jour il ya
quelqu'un qui m'a ouvert
j'essaie de proposer mes services ça a
fonctionné et j'ai même eu plusieurs
petits clients donc au moment là j'avais
mes petites cartes de visite imprimés en
ligne
c'était petit jardinier sauvetage de
jardin en friche j'ai même un slogan
et je pouvais aller au cinéma ça va
continuer comme ça j'ai fini mes études
je m'apprête à me lancer dans la vie
active
un jour je vais même à la piscine avec
ma copine qui était mignonne en plus moi
j'avais une copine elle nage je
m'apprête à faire un beau plongeon de 3
m je saute et elle se met pile en
dessous soit je lui tombe dessus ça fait
un gros massacre soit il faut trouver
une solution
je suis déjà j'ai déjà sauté donc au
moment là j'essaye de l'esquivé j'ai
réussi
mais je me suis raté c'est à dire que
les pieds on t'appelle dernier ma tête
je me suis décalé le bassin enfoncé une
lombaire écrasé un ou deux disques est
ressorti juste la force de mes bras
moyen très moyen comme un malheur
n'arrive jamais seul elle m'a quittée en
plus mon si mignonne soit elle je me
suis fait virer de chez moi au moment là
j'étais un peu en train de virer connard
donc ma mère a été obligé de me virer de
la maison tu crise d'adolescence assez
violente et tardif
c'était pour mon bien ça doit être dur
pour elle ça a été dur aussi pour moi
donc je me suis retrouvé seul dans mon
petit studio avec le dos cassé au
chômage je déprime et il vaut bonheur
ses moyens tu quand même essayé de me
relancer tranquillement
heureusement j'aime bien créer des
petites choses et j'aime bien la
peinture
donc j'ai décidé de me relancer j'avais
un peu découvert la peinture avec un
tableau de la mer un petit comme ça
c'était pas un rembrandt c'était juste
de l'art abstrait ça faisait des balles
petite bande avec différents types de
texture je sais pas j'étais fasciné par
ce petit tableau
donc j'ai décidé de peindre un petit peu
pour sortir un peu tout ce que j'avais
et avancer j'en ai fait un deux trois au
bout d'un moment j'ai un peu manqué de
peinture donc il fallait bien que je
fasse quelque chose je vais pas
forcément beaucoup d'argent non plus au
moment là donc j'ai décidé d'en vendre
je vais me crée un petit internet une
page facebook leur vendait aux amis je
me racheter de la voiture et je
continuer à avancer
ça m'a permis de ressortir de chez moi
reprendre un peu goût à la vie et de me
relancer un plaster partie et là j'ai
fait à peu près tous les boulots
possibles et imaginables que ce soit
jardinier
et j'ai fait barman serveur livreur de
pizza voilà je vais vraiment fait vendre
de fruits et légumes de vêtements à
chaque fois avec le sourire ce que
j'apprenais des choses jamais plus de
six mois parce qu'au bout d'un moment je
m'ennuyais mais ça m'a permis de me
relancer et d'être prêt pour le
clafoutis
je me suis pris un clafoutis en pleine
face heureusement c'est al asri c'était
mon préféré d'ailleurs si vous avez des
supercars recettes de clafoutis à l'ars
à la cerise pourra se voir après on en
discutera mais bon donc le clafoutis à
la cerise ça s'est présenté en fait j'ai
eu les cerises d'un cousin et je voulais
absolument me faire ce clafoutis
je commence à les couper les nettoyer et
en fait il y en avait une ou deux
véreuses impossible de faire ce
clafoutis c'est pas grave je me suis dit
que j'allais trouver une solution donc
je les ai mis dans de l'alcool du rhum
ce que je vivais à l'époque puisque je
faisais un petit peu les bars oui
j'allais paquet aussi des bas mais j'ai
appris plein de choses c'était
professionnel j'ai mis un peu de vanille
un morceau de cannelle et en fait j'ai
créé mon premier rhum arrangé comme dans
les îles mais en lorraine et c'était
super bon du coup j'ai décidé d'en faire
d'autres
même donner des recettes aux amis pour
qu'ils essayent de le faire mais ce
qu'ils faisaient était un peu moyen du
coup il aimait bien le rhum arrangé
il invitait pas que pour ça il aimait
bien je savais le faire
et eux non je dis bon il ya peut-être
moyen de faire quelque chose du coup les
faire un peu pour eux en plus ce moment
là je me suis retrouvé dans mon
appartement avec plein de bouteilles et
ma copine de l'époque
oui ça fait une autre copine mignonne
aussi m'a dit quelque chose ça m'a fait
un petit déclic hamad il faut faire
quelque chose du rhum partout dans
l'appartement
c'était vrai est ce le déclic que j'ai
eu c'est super je vais me lancer et le
faire de façon officielle et du coup
créer encore une petite entreprise
je regarde pour essayer de me lancer et
faire ce métier en fait c'est existait
pas j'ai regardé sur les forums c'était
même impossible vu que c'est bien tu es
tu j'ai essayé
alors j'ai regardé j'ai mis à peu près
un an et demi pour réussir à créer cette
entreprise de rhums arrangés
déjà rien que acheter du rhum il faut
pas aller au supermarché d'à côté que
son caddie c'est pas possible j'ai
vraiment galéré pour réussir à trouver
du rhum et puis réussir à créer une
entreprise qui me ressemble un petit peu
c'est pas facile non plus j'aime bien le
côté local écolo serrer des mains
donc pour sucrer mes recettes je me suis
dit je prends du miel qui vient d'à côté
de chez moi plutôt sympa puis aussi
essayer de mettre un petit peu ma patte
que j'ai aussi utilisé le surnom que
j'avais à l'époque d'andreu llach parce
que là bas je m'appelle kevin julia qu
il fallait une petite semaine en espagne
en vacances et j'ai fait un tout petit
peu la fête et on m'a appelé deux
d'entre eux l'irak et à la fiesta
oui j'ai gagné mais du coup c'était mon
surnom d'oncle et mis dessus quitte à
mettre un petit logo en fait j'ai
utilisé ce que ma petite soeur a fait 13
ans sur un coin de table me dessiner
avec les cheveux tout éclater et un
fruit dans la tête car ils traînent des
jeunes d'ailleurs même là le cas trésor
il m'a aidé à faire le logo et on a même
mis la petite phrase il a un fruit dans
le bocal rome décalé bonhomme aussi
décalé parce que le but ce n'était pas
faire comme dans les îles il travaille
très bien
ils ont des fruits frais des recettes
ancestrales j'adore ce qu'ils font est
donc pour ça je voulais pas faire pareil
parce que pour moi ce serait
complètement pillé leurs cultures je
voulais pas donc je voulais mettre ma
patte
donc on travaille en essayer de faire un
petit peu ce qui me ressemble j'ai même
pu faire le premier rhum arrangé au
monde aux houblons que j'adore aussi la
bière et le houblon c'est une plante
aromatique qui va permettre voilà de
donner un peu de goût à la bière et
savait jamais été fait
j'ai mis six ans et demi mais j'ai créé
mon premier roman rangé aux houblons
parce que je suis têtu et en plus c'est
bon
et donc voilà créer des recettes ça me
fait plaisir et je sais pas comment vous
expliquer comment je crée une recette
c'est assez étrange
par exemple je vais avoir plein de
fruits et d'épicés différents je vais
les mettre dans des petites fioles et
régulièrement je vais les gouttes et les
sentir par exemple il y en a un je goûte
cd physalis souvient d'amérique latine
je sens pas grand chose ensuite je goûte
ya un côté fruité acidulées franchement
super et juste après rien bon pas grave
je mémorise et je continue à côté
d'autres choses elle ajoute de la fève
de tonka
ça vient d'amérique latine aussi je sens
un bon goût d'amande de frangipane ces
gourmands je goûte rien du tout et après
une bonne note d'amendé vraiment le côté
gourmand et en fait je sais pas trop
comment je fais mais dans ma tête j'ai
bouché le trou est ce qui a donné
quelque chose avec une bonne notes
d'amande gourmande
ensuite on boit on a quelque chose de
fruité d'acidulé et après la petite note
gourmande qui revient voilà comment j'ai
créé par exemple le physalis tonka une
recette assez sympa donc franchement par
rapport au bonheur tout se passait bien
j'avais mon entreprise qui se
développait gens d'aimer petite
bouteille tout est cool et là j'ai
travaillé un peu plus ce qu'il faut
travailler dur moment là donc j'ai moins
vu les amis je travaillais aussi dur
donc je me suis un peu moins occupé de
la copine puis je te remets un peu moins
mais je travaille vraiment beaucoup
du coup je fatigue et donc l'entreprise
fatigué aussi et elle a commencé un peu
à péricliter voire même se casser la
gueule
la copine vu qu'ils avaient délaissées
pas mal est parti un mois avant le
mariage
un peu fait fuir et les amis
heureusement ça revient toujours après
case départ happart seul mon entreprise
quasiment morte
la moitié des primes et et je sais pas
trop quoi faire bon j'ai l'habitude de
tomber au bout d'un moment d'habitude je
me relève c'est reparti
c'est assez dur j'ai essayé de redresser
l'entreprise en travaillant mais mieux
c'est à dire que je prenais aussi des
pauses et j'allais voir les amis après
j'essaie de rouvrir les yeux leur
profiter de la vie donc ça c'était cool
j'ai tellement ouvert les yeux que je
vais même réussi à retrouver mon associé
ça faisait au moins trois ans que je le
cherchais et ils étaient juste là
il m'aidait depuis le début il m'a même
aidé pour mettre le premier site en
ligne au début m des autocollants sur la
voiture ou faire des travaux mais je
l'avais pas vu ce que j'étais trop
focalisé dedans et ça marchait pas donc
j'ai trouvé ce super associés qui me
permet un peu quand en plus il a même
philosophie de moi c'est à dire que le
côté humain c'est important par rapport
à ce qu'on nous dit différents rhums
arrangés il ya plein de concurrence même
si je suis le troisième à m'être lancé
il y en a plein maintenant et on nous a
dit voilà il ya plein de concurrence non
notre philosophie c'est qu'à pas de
concurrence on a soit des confrères qui
font la même chose qui s'amusent et font
des bonds rhum arrangé
il ya ceux qui copient pour l'argent et
eux c'est des connards donc des
confrères des connards c'est tout voilà
on aime bien le côté humain est un peu
comme quand je faisais de la peinture
j'avais besoin de nouveaux pinceaux
nouvelle peinture
on associe va réussir à ma porte et ça
donc il s'appelle alex
il va aider à développer le site
internet
là comme fer les relances facture ça
peut paraître con mais c'est un gros
boulot et moi j'aime pas lui se
débrouille très bien et va me trouver
les outils pour travailler pour réussir
à créer mes petites recettes par exemple
on a maintenant des petits gobelets en
pl à ces de l'amidon de maïs c'est
compostables écolo super sympa j'avais
toutes les caractéristiques mais je n'ai
pas trouvé
je lui en ai parlé il est allé sur
internet c'est bon on en a maintenant il
vraiment forte
donc voilà ça repart tranquillement on a
notre bonne philosophie aussi profiter
de la vie à côté mes l'entreprise repart
le petit chemin vers le bonheur ça se
passe bien
franchement c'est plutôt cool c'est
peut-être pour ça du coup qui m'ont
invité aujourd'hui pour le côté
passionné et bonheur mais passionné pour
moi enfin je sais pas si je suis
passionné c'est à dire que seulement
toutes les choses que je fais même un
film je trouve ça extraordinaire
mais à mon avis il faut pas essayer de
faire quelque chose d'extra plus tard
pour être heureux mais trouver extra
absolument tout ce qu'on fait tout le
temps ça pour moi c'est important dans
la semaine dernière je suis allé dans la
nature et j pris un petit peu de lierre
jeu les ramener dans mon appartement je
les replanter il pousse suis content
vraiment c'est peut-être juste ça en
fait être heureux puis faire des petites
choses nouvelles
ils m'ont invité aujourd'hui alors que
je suis extrêmement timide
là j'ai un peu peur enfin je suis mort
de trouille mais je suis venu ce qu'ils
font un peu sortir de sa zone de confort
et c'est de faire des nouvelles choses
d'apprendre donc foule venue ici et je
peux vous voir tous ces super sympa et
du coup d'une certaine façon vous
m'aidez donc vous êtes tous ma petite
étincelle d'inspiration merci et
j'espère à mon tour pouvoir vous
inspirer un peu donc soyez heureux et
merci beaucoup de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]